[Musique]
trop tard masque parce beaucoup de
personnes les maires en particulier les
directeurs d'école jusqu'à présent
n'avait aucune autorité sur les
professeurs de l'école qu'il dirige
voilà une curieuse anomalie alors qu'ils
ont des responsabilités de plus en plus
lourdes en termes de sécurité de lutte
contre la pandémie en face il n'avait
pas l'autorité fonctionnelle pour
assurer ses responsabilités ce que le
sénat fait c'est de leur donner une
autorité fonctionnelle les directeurs de
mer auront en face d'eux responsabilités
de plus en plus loupé les compétences et
les moyens pour assurer notre
[Musique]
ce que le sénat a voulu aussi c'est que
des directeurs d'école et plus de temps
nous avons travaillé le processus de
décharge et directeur académique rond
l'obligation de rendre compte de la
manière dont ils déchargent de temps
d'enseignement des directeurs pour
qu'ils puissent exercer leurs fonctions
et chaque année un rapport sera fait qui
permettra de voir si le directeur
d'école ont vraiment le temps d'exercer
leurs fonctions c'est un métier complexe
et nous avons voulu aussi qu' aucun
professeur d'école ne soit nommé
directeur sans avoir reçu une formation
initiale préalable à l'inscription sur
la liste d'aptitude amédée complexe qui
nécessite de l'information et de la
formation continue et c'est le sénat qui
a souhaité que cette formation continue
et l'ua a minima tous les cinq ans je
crois qu'on a répondu à la tente des
directeurs qui auront maintenant une
autorité plus de formation et plus de
temps pour exercer leurs fonctions dont
on a bien mesure avec la pandémie
qu'elle était essentielle
[Musique]